Certaines histoires
sont inoubliables.
Même par temps nuageux,
le soleil peut briller.
Celle de mon grand-père
a enrichi la mienne.
Vous voyez, les contes sont transmis
de génération en génération
et ne peuvent être oubliés.
C'est l'histoire
de Roland-Garros.
Vous n'oublierez jamais la première fois
que vous franchissez les portes,
lorsque vous êtes plongé
dans cette atmosphère unique,
lorsque vous découvrez
ce lieu magique.
et les emblématiques panamas.
Ne laissez pas le vôtre s'échapper !
Sentez-vous battre votre cœur,
comme si la terre s’arrêtait de tourner ?
OK, ça commence, restez concentré!
Et admirez ces chevaliers des temps modernes
qui se battent pour la couronne.
Écoutez la foule, acclamations, chants, sifflements...
Cela ne changera jamais.
Seuls les plus grands champions
Peuvent remporter le titre
lors de ce tournoi emblématique :
Roland-Garros.
Alors, qu’est-ce que tu en penses ?
Certaines histoires
sont inoubliables.